madame monsieur bonsoir chronique d'une
guerre oubliée les combats font à
nouveau rage à kigali la capitale
rwandaise des bombardements provoque un
nouvel exode dramatique de la population
civile
réfugiés dans les camps de fortune nos
envoyés spéciaux eric meunier et pierre
laurent constants ont pu effectuer une
reconnaissance macabre dans ce pays
martyr accompagné ou plutôt guidé entre
guillemets par un officier tout si
l'odeur est pestilentielle les corps en
décomposition de familles entières bande
encore la route entre la frontière
tanzanienne et kigali
les a surpris dans leur maison d'autres
froidement exécuté les mains liées dans
le dos sans doute pour prouver l'ampleur
du massacre
les rebelles du front populaire rwandais
le fpr qui a repris la région à l'armée
gouvernementale ne se sont toujours pas
décidé à enterrer ses morts il balade
les journalistes une sorte de safari de
l'horreur malgré l'appel du fpr leur
garantissant la sécurité plus de trois
semaines après la tuerie ils sont encore
rares les réfugiés rwandais a osé
revenir dans leurs villages
la guerre ici n'a jamais été entre les
deux ethnies hutus et tutsis laguérie
s'y oppose les démocrates aux dictateurs
qui ont commis ces massacres que vous
voyez à une trentaine de kilomètres
seulement de kigali où les combats à
l'armé lourde continue l'hôpital de
gainey le dernier en état de fonctionner
dans la région
médecins du monde il ya ramené une
équipe chirurgicale aussitôt la fin du
massacre
on y croise aussi les premières missions
exploratoires du comité international de
la croix rouge qui tentent d'évaluer la
situation à l'hôpital de ghazni
les patients sont souvent très jeunes
principalement d'ethnie tutsi le plus
souvent mutilés d'un bras ou d'une jambe
ou blessé à la tête par de redoutables
planche à clous larmes préférer les
exécuteurs j'ai essayé de fuir avec ma
famille mais les miliciens ont tiré une
balle dans la jambe
dans ma famille tout le monde a été tué
ils voulaient tuer aussi les enfants
tutsi
surtout les garçons pour les empêcher
plus tard de se venger
quant à gainey il y avait un hôpital
c'est maintenant aussi un orphelinat